[Musik]
alarmstimmung in der wirtschaft neue
einschränkungen wegen steigender corona
zahlen wären kaum zu verkraften waren
wohnungen
dicht gedrängt und ohne mundschutz in
berlin ignorieren tausende die
hygieneregeln und demonstrieren gegen
die krone politik der regierung und tik
tok unter spionageverdacht donald trump
für die chinesische videoplattform in
den usa verbieten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und haben zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesen ersten
august samstag an meiner seite ist rudi
cerne für den sport hallo schön mit
wachsender unruhe reagieren politik und
wirtschaft auf die steigenden
neuinfektionen wirtschaftsminister
altmaier plädiert dafür verstöße gegen
korona regeln strenger zu ahnden
sachsen-anhalts ministerpräsident
haseloff warnt einem zweiten locker und
können wir uns nicht leisten
die regierung hat bereits
milliardenhilfen bereitgestellt um den
wirtschaftlichen einbruch abzufedern
trotzdem ist die wirtschaftsleistung
zwischen april und juni um historische
10,1 prozent gesunken was steigt sind
die neuinfektionen im sieben tage
schnitt haben sich 680 menschen
angesteckt 20 mehr als gestern luden
leinhos berechnet sie sollen ein
wichtiges mittel gegen die befürchtete
zweite corona welle seien neue mobile
teststationen wie diese hier am
fährhafen auf der ostseeinsel fehmarn
doch nur wenige rückreisende aus
schweden und dänemark nutzen bislang die
chance ich versteh gar nicht was hier im
moment noch so viele autos vorbeifahren
und niemand weniger anhalten und steht
ja auch jetzt wieder jemand und ich habe
gehört dass soll ab montag pflicht
werden dass ich auch richtig finde aber
ich weiß nicht wie das logistisch
handhabbar sein soll der anfang heute
mit hindernissen dabei sollen die nun
kostenlosen tests helfen drastisch
verschärfte corona aufladen zu vermeiden
auch deutschlands geschäfte und betriebe
sollen nicht noch einmal still stehen
für jene sünder forderte
wirtschaftsminister härtere strafen wer
ohne maske bus oder bahn fährt gefährdet
nicht sich selbst sondern andere wenn
eine party in einer engen kellerkneipe
und der verstoß gegen alle abstands und
hygienevorschriften zum super spreading
event wird ist das keine lappalie und
muss notfalls auch bestraft werden
die auch durch unvernunft steigenden
infektionszahlen machen auch vielen
ökonomen sorgen denn viele unternehmen
hätten schon in der ersten welle ihre
rücklagen aufgebraucht
diese rücklagen existieren und nicht nur
deswegen ist natürlich zu erwarten dass
eine zweite infektion eine zweite welle
der beschränkungen mehr unternehmen
tatsächlich in die pleite
bringt deshalb müssten begrenzte
infektionsherde auch bei steigenden
zahlen weiter regional zielgerichtet
bekämpft werden
eine forderung der auch der frankfurter
biologe martin strom mehr zustimmt ein
relativ schwieriger spagat in die
politik da gehen muss und ich denke aber
dass es ein ausgewogenes szenario geben
sollte und aufgrund der erfahrung denke
ich dass wir den tatsächlich den
kompletten lockdown wirklich verhindern
können
entscheidend sei vor allem so genannte
super spreading ereignisse zu verhindern
wo zu viele menschen auf engem raum und
ohne masken zusammenkommen
trotz aller appelle und warnungen gibt
es nach wie vor einige die masken
pflicht und abstandsregeln für völligen
quatsch halten in berlin gingen heute
nach polizeiangaben rund 17.000
demonstranten darunter auch
rechtsextremisten gegen die korona
auflagen auf die straße sowie die otn
wenn die spd-chefin esken
gesundheitsminister sparen twitterte ja
demonstrationen müssen auch in corona
zeiten möglich seien aber nicht so sehr
wie berichtet
beim aufmarsch der querdenker wurde
schnell klar alle eint der protest gegen
die korona auflagen
[Applaus]
sie sehen sich als mündige bürger
protestieren ohne maske ohne abstand
denn corona halten sie für propaganda
leben wieder handeln weil ich dafür bin
dass unsere kinder wieder kinder sein
dürfen
gut 20.000 ziehen durch berlins mitte
fordern ein ende aller staatlichen
corona maßnahmen als permanenter
durchsagen der polizei hielt sich kaum
jemand an die gene maßnahmen trotz
steigender infektionszahlen wird das
ende der seuche verkündet genau groß ist
die pandemie vorbei worden
ich habe gegen protest am rande des demo
zuges sie wollen die korona rebellen vor
rechtsextremen und antisemiten warnen
die im zug der virus leugner mit
marschieren menschen gehen zum teil
schulter an schulter mit rechtsextremen
mit verschwörung sie werden mit denen
die vor allem eines ein
der hass gegenüber die politische elite
gegen weil die da die anschließende
kundgebung in der straße des 17 juni
wurde wegen zu wenig abstand und
fehlender masken von der polizei
abgebrochen die teilnehmer wurden
gebieten nach hause zu gehen aber viele
blieben einfach sitzen
die krone regeln wären gerne auch da
missachtet wo kräftig gefeiert wird das
war zuletzt in diversen städten zu
beobachten je mehr alkohol desto mehr
lief das ganze aus dem gut ab auch in
hamburg das an diesem wochenende
neue wege geht so sei es die letzten
wochende abende im schanzenviertel aus
partytreiben in der lauen sommernacht
weil appelle nicht halfen hat der senat
ein verkaufsverbot von alkohol
angeordnet ab 20 uhr gibt es nichts mehr
und das scheint zu wirken sven regn
berichtet
auf der reeperbahn nachts um zwei hat
amtsarzt marc-andre röske viel zu
erklären warum hinter dem tresen immer
masken pflicht herrscht und dass der
imbiss keinen alkohol verkaufen da die
betreiber sind natürlich der meinung
dass sie eigentlich viel richtig
umsetzen aber wir merken natürlich schon
die verstöße im nacken aber auch wie die
warnungen unter den läden eigentlich
erfolgt es gibt kein bier auf der
reeperbahn zumindest nicht im
straßenverkauf deutschlands erstes
corona alkohol verkaufsverbot gilt
dieses wochenende von 20 bis 6 uhr
morgens die stadt möchte keine wilden
party szene mehr
diese maßnahme passt eigentlich nicht
zusammen pauli weil st pauli verspricht
die reeperbahn verspricht die große
freiheit wir haben aber an den letzten
wochen einige merkt dass zu viele
menschen diese freiheit auch zu sehr
ausgenutzt haben und sich an keinerlei
regeln mehr gehalten haben etwas abseits
der trubel meile hält sich nicht jeder
an die verkaufsverbots regel diese
ausschank muss ganz dicht machen
er hat das geschäft das wir hier dunkel
sehen betreibt er seit jahren nutzt es
aber nicht sondern nutzt immer den
abverkauf weil das offensichtlich auch
mehr finanzielle möglichkeiten bietet in
den restaurants und kneipen dürfen die
besucher alkohol trinken nur der
deutlich günstigere straßenverkauf ist
nachts verboten das was du halt in so
laden kostet die maßnahme scheint zu
wirken selbst in der großen freiheit gab
es in der vergangenen nacht noch freie
ecken bleibt es auch heute und morgen
abend friedlich soll das verkaufsverbot
eine einmalige antwort man bleiben zur
außenpolitik die hong kong politik
chinas führt zu spannungen mit
deutschland peking wirft berlin vor sich
in seine inneren angelegenheiten
einzumischen und spricht von einem
ernsten verstoß gegen internationales
recht
china reagiert damit auf außenminister
maß der hatte gestern das
auslieferungsabkommen mit hongkong
ausgesetzt nachdem die parlamentswahlen
dort um ein jahr verschoben wurden
die polizei spricht von einem
fremdenfeindlichen übergriff in erfurt
sind drei junge männer aus guinea in der
vergangenen nacht angegriffen worden
zwei wurden verletzt einer von ihnen
schwer zeitweise schwebte er in
lebensgefahr
zwölf mutmaßliche täter wurden vorläufig
festgenommen
das thüringische landeskriminalamt
ermittelt nach polen wo dieser erste
august ein tag des erinnerns ist an den
warschauer aufstand für 6 und 4 76
jahren und den mut sich der
naziherrschaft entgegenzustellen
rückblick ins jahr 1954 seit fünf jahren
erlebt das land brutale unterdrückung
durch die deutschen besatzer dem wir die
polnische heimatarmee ein ende bereiten
und startet den versuch die hauptstadt
zu befreien
63 tage dauert ihr aussichtsloser kampf
für den die deutschen blutige rache
nehmen über das gedenken in warschau
natalie steger die 63 tage aufstand
sieht die allgegenwärtig wann der drudge
xcover 17 als im warschauer aufstand
kämpfte ihre aufgabe so erzählt sie uns
war es granaten zu werfen
gegen die deutschen besatzer ich sah
einen leidenden deutschen soldaten der
so sehr auseinander gerissen wurde dass
ich anfing zu weinen
aber ich habe weiter granaten geworfen
bis zum ende
weil es ein kampf um leben und tod war
um 17 uhr eine schweigeminute
um diese uhrzeit begann der warschauer
aufstand vor 76 jahren
den ganzen tag über gedenken an die
polnischen opfer damals standen sie auch
mit der waffe in der hand in einem
ungleichen kampf gegen deutschland
hitler deutschland der erste august 1944
die polnische heimatarmee führt im
untergrund den kampf gegen die deutschen
nach zwei monaten legen die nazis aus
rache fast die komplette stadt in schutt
und asche
etwa 200.000 polen werden getötet
wandert schikowski ist eine der letzten
noch lebenden kämpferinnen des aufstands
doch sie will nicht nur nach hinten
blicken
wir haben eine wundervolle situation
weil wir in der europäischen union sind
in der wir uns anfreunden und
verständigen können
das ist die hoffnung für mich und so
steht das erinnern gleichzeitig als
mahnung für ein nie wieder ganz anderes
thema jetzt unbekannte hätten die
twitter-konten von prominenten in den
usa vor zwei wochen war das eine
schlagzeile
jetzt haben us behörden drei verdächtige
festgenommen
drahtzieher soll ein 17 jähriger aus
freude sein
die attacke traf unter anderem ex
präsident barack obama microsoft gründer
bill gates und tesla chef elon musk über
deren twitter konten wurde aufgerufen
bitcoins auf ein bestimmtes konto zu
schicken
so erbeuteten die verdächtigen mehr als
100.000 us dollar von twitter zu tik tok
vor allem jugendliche lieben die
chinesische videoplattformen die zum
beispiel solche tanzclubs bietet
[Musik]
tipptopp hat 800 millionen nutzerinnen
und nutzer weltweit davon 100 millionen
in den usa
sie gilt als die am schnellsten
wachsende social media app macht us
produkten wie instagram und facebook
konkurrenz
doch es gibt massive bedenken dass daten
nach china abfließen und deshalb will
präsident ram tik tok in den usa jetzt
verbieten
peter jäger berichtet die tik tok welt
sie ist kreativ und bot vor allem promis
kinder und jugendliche toben sich auf
der smartphone app aus und neben
tanzeinlagen und wimpernzange nutzen
viele user die videoschnipsel auch immer
mehr für politisches denken die
chinesische plattform ist eine gefahr
für die nationale sicherheit findet
us-präsident schon jetzt droht er mit
einem tick tock verbot im eigenen land
wir beobachten tik tok werden das
vielleicht verbieten oder wehtun andere
dinge wir haben optionen später aber
sagt trump vor journalisten er wehrte
tik tok aus den usa verbannen weil er
befürchtet dass nutzerdaten vom
chinesischen app betreiber bei dance an
die regierung in peking weitergereicht
werden
tik tok bestreitet dass die
deutschlandzentrale schreibt dem zdf
weder hat die chinesische regierung die
herausgabe von daten verlangt noch würde
tik tok dieser forderung nachkommen
nutzerinnen und nutzer daten von tik tok
werden in den vereinigten staaten und
singapur gespeichert und verarbeitet
auch viele netz experten bezweifeln tik
tok unabhängigkeit vermuten hinter toms
drohung aber in erster linie eine neue
politische episode in duell mit china in
deutschland gibt es keine überlegungen
zu verbieten
es wird eigentlich auch sowieso eher als
industriepolitischer strategischer zug
der amerikaner und der inder gesehen
diese app zu verbieten weil sie halt
eben sehr stark sichtbar chinesisch ist
und machte damit wie bei ebay also auch
chinesischen markt initiativen
ein bisschen nähe in die seite grätschen
will tram hat auch noch eine persönliche
rechnung mit tik tok offen nutzer hatten
im juni offenbar seinen auftritt in
salza sabotiert reservierten massenhaft
tickets ohne sie zu nutzen
leere ränge haben dem us präsidenten und
gar nicht gefallen
jetzt was schönes festivals in corona
zeiten das ist eigentlich ein sehr
überschaubares kapitel denn fast alles
wurde abgesagt in berlin aber startet
heute young euro classic und damit die
hoffnung dass es vielleicht langsam
wieder losgehen könnte
seit jahrzehnten kommen jeden sommer
zwei wochen lang jugendorchester aus
aller welt ins konzerthaus am
gendarmenmarkt ein publikumsrenner
diesmal eben in der pandemie variante
jetzt schneider das chaos ensemble probt
griechische tänze von nikos katers
für die meisten musiker ist der auftritt
heute abend der erste seit monaten
diese perspektivlosigkeit das war schon
also dass man so einen status quo
gefangen war nicht wusste wie das dann
in vier wochen wieder aussieht oder in
acht wochen das war schon sehr hart so
deswegen ist es natürlich das wird also
für alle beteiligten glaube ich also
unglaublich erfüllend das programm des
festivals wurde an corona angepasst
kammermusik statt großer orchester jede
zweite stuhlreihe im saal ist ausgebaut
nach zwei sitzplätzen sind drei gesperrt
es ist so dass wir maximal auf der bühne
30 musiker haben dürfen aber auch nur in
bestimmten konstellationen und im haus
sind es bei uns normalerweise knapp 1500
sitzplätze die wir verkaufen und in
diesem jahr sind es 350 aber nicht jeder
künstler in berlin hat das glück wieder
auftreten zu können eine spendenaktion
soll etwas hilfe bringen niemand kommt
alle sind dabei heißt sie es gibt
tickets für ein festival das nicht
stattfindet der erlös wird ein bewerber
verteilt wir bieten jetzt 1000 euro an
als unterstützung das ist sozusagen für
einen muss man ja sagen troika weise
prekär lebenden künstler künstlerin
schon ne möglichkeit knapp einen monat
vielleicht teilweise damit klar zu
kommen
bis montag kann gespendet werden die
concert welt schaut gespannt auf die
young euro classic generalprobe geht
alles gut so ist das momentan eine
mögliche perspektive für die gesamte
branche
jetzt duru die mit einem formel 1 in
häufiger in der tat lewis hamilton fährt
in seinem mercedes in einer anderen liga
beim qualifying zum britischen grand
prix in silverstone vor der weltmeister
mit streckenrekord zu 91 zwischen
sebastian vettel erlebte in seinem
ferrari die nächste enttäuschung r
startet morgen von platz zehn aus ins
vierte saisonrennen eine
traditionsrennstrecke leergefegt
silverstone ohne zuschauer wo sonst
hunderttausende ihrer rennsport passion
frönen
weltmeister hamilton mit ungewohnten
fehlern im qualifying um am ende doch
wieder zujubeln siebte pole auf dieser
rennstrecke formel-1-rückkehrer nico
hülkenberg als ersatz für den corona
positiven perez noch nicht im einklang
mit seinem racing points rang 11 für den
deutschen
nur unwesentlich besser sebastian vettel
fehler reiht sich ein fehler der ferrari
scheint für den viermaligen weltmeister
und vater zu sein mehr als der zehnte
platz ist nicht drin
ich habe mich schwergetan den rhythmus
zu finden das auto war generell in
ordnung aber er wollte nicht ganz so wie
ich heute mercedes haushoch überlegen
der drittplatzierte fast appen schon
eine sekunde zurück schale claire
aufwand 4 und für hamilton gilt er kann
sich wohl nur selbst schlagen
nationalspieler maximilian kleber hat
mit seinen dallas mavericks das
auftaktspiel beim saison finale der
basketball profiliga nba auf
spektakuläre weise verloren den houston
rockets unterlagen die mavs nach
verlängerung in orlando florida mit 149
zu 153 die black knights meter aktion
während der hymne hatte die nba
angekündigt es folgt eine james hagen
show vom allerfeinsten dem shooting
guard der houston rockets genannte bild
gelingen 49 der 153 punkte die mavericks
mit dem deutschen maxi kleber zur pause
und kurz vor dem ende immer in führung
aber james hagen treibt seine rockets
immer wieder an
am ende gewinnt houston das texanische
duell mit 153 zu 149 und noch ein
erfolgreiches comeback für kira
walkenhorst die beachvolleyball
olympiasiegerin qualifiziert sich mit
ihrer neuen partnerin anna lena grüne
für die deutschen meisterschaften nicht
nur der sand glüht beim
ausscheidungsturnier in düsseldorf bei
temperaturen von über 30 grad gewinnt
das neu formierte duo oben im bild das
finalspiel gegen victoria bieneck und
julia hofmann glatt in zwei sätzen
erfrischung wird jetzt auch ganz gut das
was vom sportlichen die hitze lässt nach
die gewitter noch nicht die details zum
wetter gleich katja horneffer das heute
journal um viertel vor elf mit claus
kleber danke für ihr interesse ich
wünsche ihnen einen unbeschwerten
samstagabend und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren höhe brauen
fotografierte heute früh über eltville
am rhein dieses schöne morgenroth und
das kündigte an dass sich das wetter
ändert vor der kaltfront von tief allen
entwickelten sich nämlich zum teil
kräftige gewitter
das ging schon heute vormittag in der
schweiz los dann zogen die gewitter die
schwäbisch hall wird die fränkische alb
und jetzt am abend und in der nacht
erwarten uns weitere unwetter zum teil
mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen und
zwar zwischen dem oberrhein und der
ostsee an der oder bleibt es dagegen
trocken und im nordwesten lockern die
wolken schon wieder auf dort sinken die
temperaturen auf 15 bis 12 grad sonst
bleibt die nacht milder bei 20 bis 16
grad
morgen ist die schwüle hitze aus
deutschland dann weg uns erwarten
höchstwerte zwischen 20 grad auf
norderney und 28 grad in der lausitz und
morgen regnet es an den alpen kräftig
weiter und es sind auch noch heftige
gewitter unterwegs zum beispiel hier in
sachsen sonne und wolken wechseln sich
dagegen ab zwischen der lüneburger heide
und der mosel und am nachmittag kann es
in norddeutschland einzelne regenschauer
geben
montag und dienstag schüttet es am
alpenrand kräftig weiter da könnten bis
zu 100 liter regen pro quadratmeter
zusammenkommen
schönes wochenende